[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and The Walking
Dead is back with its midseason finale
that definitely serves as a satisfying
cliffhanger for everything that we've
seen so far episode 8 has a lot to
unpack from it and throughout this video
I'm gonna be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the last
entry of the air as well as what we can
take from the ending there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch the episode yet then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you but click in this video
now let's get into episode 8 the episode
opens ominously with alpha telling Dante
about her plan and how he must
infiltrate the camp and gain their trust
it chronicles the characters journey and
showcases how he was able to gain the
friendship of the survivors pretending
to be a victim of the apocalypse that
just needed a place to stay it perfectly
recontextualizes the entire series and
shows just how manipulative alpha really
is using her mole is a way to build
paranoia in the camp making everyone
turn on one another
I think this is one of the best intros
for the series so far and it paints out
just how much of a lie that the truce
really was with alpha massively
manipulating those behind the scenes
Dante was the perfect killer sneaking
into the sick and diseased people's
homes and killing them whilst they were
at their most vulnerable we learned that
Lydia had never met Dante so this is why
she never identified him and thus he was
the best double agent that there could
be it's a chilling introduction that
really shows just how good the series
has become once more and we catch up to
the character in the present with him
just having strangled Siddiq Rosita
stops by and discovers Dante who tries
to stab her and cover up his crime he
didn't count on Siddiq coming back to
life though and the recently reanimated
corpse struts back into the house almost
going for his and Rosita's child which
forces her to kill him and then beat the
crap out of Dante Dante later gets
interrogated and insists that he liked
Sadiq and that he only killed him out of
necessity but Rosita can't shake off the
fact that
X did try and eat their baby the line
it's okay in natures sometimes parents
eat their young
Daunte others in the episode shows just
how much he's lost his grip on humanity
and that all the whisperers are like
this and that they need to be taken down
juxtaposing this he knows that the group
still hold on to their humanity tightly
and that they will treat him like they
tried negan it really is a comment on
society and how the tolerant often
become victims to their good nature by
letting those that don't share their
morals get away with things that are
deplorable on the other side of the
territory Aaron meets with gamma and the
to trade Intel Aaron wants to know the
workings of the whisperers and gamma
just want to know if their nephew is
safe and sound gamma is a really
important figure in this episode as she
knows where the Horde is located which
we learn is apparently at a sunken field
on the edge of the forest
the survivors realize that alpha now
knows all of their plans operations and
so on and this has moved up the timeline
of that counter-attack Carroll
reinforces that Lydia doesn't want to be
found and she has a real heart-to-heart
with Darrel on the way to Oceanside we
read John Judith Michonne and a definite
dead man walking Luke I'm surprised he
survives this episode as yeah the guy
gave a big farewell to everyone like
three episodes ago and he's still around
so well done pal if at three or even
four week wait between seeing them last
time like I can t remember when it was
it was that long ago wasn't long enough
for Michonne she decides to take a side
quest in order to get Judith a library
book I guess in this world they don't
have Nintendo switches so you just have
to keep yourself occupied with what you
can find here Luke is grabbed by walkers
and just as you think it's time for him
to go and play the big hop in the sky
sheet music in hand a mystery man pops
up saving him before vanishing an ocean
side he reappears apparently trying to
steal supplies but he says he just wants
to get home paranoia is high and there
are suspicions that he may be a
whisperer especially as he's using a
similar tactic as Dante did didn't Phil
trade the group walkers start to walk
her this way into the camp so sorry
about that terrible job and he tries to
escape though his time on the run is a
little shoo lived we eventually learned
that his name is Virgil and he's from a
naval base in Chesapeake Bay and in
exchange for his return home Michonne
wants guns and a Moe's from the base and
this hints at the fact
going forward they're gonna need them in
order to take the Horde down I know I
know I say this every week but surely
the whisperers come in like [ __ ] you
can't keep dragging this out right look
ya'll alright y'all gonna do it on you
I'm glad Michonne is networking at least
because as we see later the group are
gone and need all those guns they can't
get nevermind there's a couple of action
bits and Eugene must have heard that
Rosita was single and ready to mingle
and he pops up to save her helping the
character to push a Walker's wig back
literally I really don't know if they're
gonna give the Padawan his shot with
Rosita but hey I guess the best way to
get a girl is to just wait till everyone
else dies great work Eugene Gabe studies
old videos of Dante like he's doing his
own heavy spoilers breakdown and Rosita
returns to see him for a shoulder to cry
on which Gabe rushes off saying she
needs to shut the hell up it's clear
that Dante is getting to them making
them doubt themselves and though he was
unearthed I really don't think that the
character failed in creating fractures
divisions and separation amongst the
group I'm just glad that no one says
don't you see this is what Alfa wants
cuz yeah that that's getting a bit
played out every time something bad
happens
Gabe visits Dante in his cell asking if
he's the world's best catfish and he
wants to know if anything that they've
been told is the truth
did he really like comment and subscribe
or was he the one disliked this entire
time I know it was you Dante Gabe
finally loses the humanity that he
somehow managed to hold on to since his
first appearance way back when and the
character completely loses it killing
Dante by stabbing him 9999 times Gabe
sort of highlights of the character that
he actually had an opportunity for a
second chance with the survivors but he
squandered it instead choosing to stick
with his first choice and it's a great
exchange between the two even if there
is a little bit of screaming at the end
now what this does cement is that the
survivors won't be holding back and that
they will be going after the whisperers
using the same dirty tactics that they
have used upon them watching Gabe go
crazy sums up the mind state of the
camps and no doubt they have all been
pushed to the edge losing their humanity
in order to fight the bigger threat in
the forest a group go looking for the
Horde and Carol and Daryl have
the heart heart with Darrell saying that
she never came back off the boat
that she's been like a ghost a ghost in
death stranding available and
PlayStation for now Carol is just
destroyed by alpha and she can't get
over what she took from her Darrell
promises she's a dead woman and
eventually the group arrived at the
apparent Horde location and find the
undead gone Carol comes face to face
with alpha for a rematch of their
staring contest and she chases after her
along with the group which leads her
into a cave that yet should have seen
this one coming guys can't you shoot her
or something now whether this was a play
by alpha and she told gamma to relay the
information that would lead them face to
face with the Horde we don't know yet
but personally I think it was all part
of the master plan alpha knows her own
soldiers better than they know
themselves and even if gamma was sincere
with this information alpha was clearly
planning on luring the scouts out to
lead them into a trap just to give them
what they wanted a horde full of the
undead we realize you need to be careful
what you wish for as the group stand
over them trapped in the cave which is
when we cut to black now going ahead I
believe that Lydia will be the one to
come and rescue them however it won't be
easy a thing that she will have made her
way back at the whisper camp and no she
never entered it spot negan who she will
be confiding in those who read the comic
know that negan is in fact a sort of
double agent himself and he and Lydia
will likely help to get them out the
sticky situation now we're gonna be
spoiling the comic book from here on out
so if you don't want to know about the
fate of our fur then I highly recommend
that you turn off now if you're still
here thanks for sticking with us but in
the comics negan is actually the one
that kills alpha and I was sure that
this was going to happen before the
mid-season finale the fact that it
hasn't makes me believe that we're going
to go in a different route and it will
indeed be Carol that finally gets her
claiming the top spot as the undefeated
staring contest winner a new thing that
negan will still play a part but it will
be more about breaking the whisperers
down from the inside after letting it
slip that Lydia is still alive with
Michonne bringing back an arsenal the
odds are gonna be even and we may
finally finally get the whisper war
before we head into the Commonwealth
storyline overall I've had a lot of fun
with this season and no it hasn't been
perfect it's still been a great course
correction for the
show and its many middling entries this
has been one of the best seasons yet and
I can't wait to see what happens when it
returns next year I will be slayed love
to hear your thoughts on The Walking
Dead midseason finale and what you've
thought of this half of the season
coming below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out my
full breakdown of the series so far
which would be linked at the end if you
go over everything you need to know
about the season and give our
predictions for where it's heading so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more we're also doing
breakdowns of HBO's Watchmen so if you
want something else on the channel to
follow then that's the perfect series to
head over to if you want to come chat to
me after the video then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey will head over to my discord
server which should be linked in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the marble phase 3 part 2 boxer on
blu-ray which contains Black Panther
infinity war and Game Captain Marvel and
more and all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on The
Walking Dead in the comments section
below the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of December and the
set will be shipped out from then to a
baguette surprise so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
you
[Music]
you
[Music]